[Music]
welcome to the iron lords podcast
i'm josh redd editor-in-chief at
lordsgaming.net and today we're going to
be unpacking and reviewing the latest
e-win flash series xl racing chair let's
take a look
the ema flash xl series chair retails
for 469 us dollars you can purchase for
20 off using the fill-in link below
the first thing striking about the chair
is the build quality the phrase you get
what you pay for is on full display here
the material quality is exceptional as
is the attention detail the tapered
sides of the main body of the chair give
way to an easy slope between padded
plates
the white contrast on the black
especially with the accent stitching
makes this chair pop
it comes equipped with lumbar and neck
support which can be adjusted as needed
and you can see each boasts the eon logo
which is a bit overkill in my opinion
but hardly detracts from the overall
style
this chair earns its xl name as well
suited by six foot four 240 pound frame
the level of customization of the
armrests with an orientation size but
using this chair in a knob of setting a
breeze to use
not only that but the oddly satisfying
quick the arm must make as you rotate
them it's perfect for me who likes to
fidget the flashback is a premium on
style and from every angle the chair
looks sharp the backing is simple black
with yet another ewin logo we're up to
four now
make no mistake this chair is big it
fills a decent portion of my living room
so make sure you keep size requirements
in mind when choosing the exit
we use the chair in both a living room
and an office setting and the ability to
fully recline makes is suitable for any
gaming session
central access is well balanced in
grease which makes it easy to spin
okay so let's talk about the rest so
i've been using this chair now for about
10 days using it for both work and for
entertainment
so i've been doing a combination of
gaming on my pc getting in my living
room and working as an office
environment and really what it comes
down to is this chair is extremely
comfortable and it's extremely versatile
it works just as well in office as it
does in my living room though it does
take up a good amount of space um we
specifically went for the xl because of
the size of my frame 6'4 240 and the
chair basically holds up really really
well my wife's been using it as well
she's obviously significantly smaller
than that and she even commented about
how the chair feels big so you can
definitely tell that this chair is made
for the size of you know a taller person
the first thing that really kind of
struck me opening it up is it's heavy
you know the build quality is
outstanding you can tell from
everything from the brush metal of the
base blades through the you know we
talked about the stitching and you've
got a better look at the foam padding in
the earlier parts of the video
and every part of it feels luxury
my written review i called it the
ferrari of gaming chairs and that's
really the case here and it even comes
with my own set of driving gloves
so they definitely have a lot of kind of
small stylistic touches that are really
they feel unnecessary uh but they feel
welcome addition so these gloves are you
know at this point they're pretty dirty
with grease the
whole of the central axis as well grease
as are the wheels and so what we found
basically was there's a reason for them
being in here and it's to keep yourself
clean when you're working it
my son and i
built the chair together he's two years
old and he is in love with it so if you
have kids there's a great chair you use
that with
what i really just kind of wanted to
highlight is that this is an expensive
chair it is almost 500
and
it feels like it it
feels like money well spent i've had
racing chairs before and
in fact i broke a gaming chair uh within
about six months of use the plastic of
the base plate cracked and i can't
imagine that happening with this chair
it's
feels together it feels very
strong structurally
and there's no sense of loss of balance
when i go into the floor recline mode
versus using it in an upright position
the
armrests i mentioned have a very
satisfying quick sound so you can hear
it here
and i ended up fidgeting with them way
too often
the real only downside to the chair that
i found besides it being expensive of
course is the neck support so you can
see that i'm sitting in an upright
position and it rests right between my
shoulder blades so i can
pull it up and use it like this
but it immediately locks back down if i
lean forward so i would have liked a
little bit more customization in terms
of being able to set the position of the
neck support
but it's extremely comfortable in the
horizontal position it feels like i'm
reclining on a pillow it's
firm but soft so pretty much everything
i'd want in a pillow so
uh it works out really nicely in the
horizontal mode and
it works fine in an office environment
just a little annoying that it
constantly slides back down
what it really comes down to with this
chair is
is it worth the price and
from my experience over the last 10 days
i have to say yes i can't imagine
meeting another chair at any point in
time again
uh as long as i have this one because
nothing
no part of it feels like there is a
structural breaking point or a
structural weak point that could
collapse at any point i mentioned before
that i have a two-year-old so i picked
the white one uh specifically so i can
look and see you know
how easy is it for him to get jam hands
all over it
and the answer is not particularly
albeit he hasn't
poured an entire box of juice on top of
it but so far there's been no sign of
any stain or residue from his
interactions with the chairs so that was
something i was concerned about but it's
held up very very well so if you're in
the market if you are a larger
person you know tall heavy whatever
uh bulky like our ceo then the fact of
the matter is
this is a really impressive product and
there's really not much
to pick apart with it
so
all in all i gave this chair at 9.2 on
our website and i could not stand by
that strongly enough
hope you enjoyed this video review make
sure you tune into lordsofgaming.net
every day for all your latest in gaming
and beyond and every sunday we have the
iron lords podcast which tells you not
what you want to hear but what you need
to hear from poison gaming i'm
editor-in-chief josh redding have a
great day
[Music]
you